[MUSIC PLAYING]
DILLON DO: My name is
Dillon Do from Google Cloud.
And I'm a technical account
manager and lead for one
of our largest customers
at Google Cloud.
My colleague technical
infrastructure lead, Swati,
here is with me today to
lead a session together.
As you may have noticed,
the title of our session
is "When aspiration
meets reality."
At Google Cloud,
we have a variety
of large and complex
projects going on.
And we wanted to share the
types of the challenges
that we've been experiencing
and also how we've
been evolving to make
migrations successful,
specifically with
some of our customers
who've been with us
close to one year.
Throughout our journey, there
have been many aspirations
around what we
wanted to achieve,
such as new technology
adoptions and products.
And we wanted to share
what was the reality
during the
implementation and how
we addressed the roadblocks.
We will open our
conversation by sharing
the approach and examples,
then discuss what we learned
and applied for our customers.
Here is our agenda for today.
We'll share the following--
first, a high level view
around the customer migration
journey at Google Cloud;
second, our migration approach;
third, aspiration versus
reality and is rational;
and finally, how we revised
our guiding principles
to reflect our
learnings from the past.
After sharing those
new guiding principles,
we'll open our session for Q&A.
So journey for migration--
when you think about the
cloud migration journey,
it may sound simple like
another migration approach.
But there are many factors
to consider, including
how we are going to
discover and identify some
of the key workload, how
we're going to plan and design
an architect the
future design, and also
plan and design how we are
going to deploy those things.
When you deploy
this workload, how
are you going to
execute and optimize
as we operate the environment?
These topics are relevant
across technology, organization,
and support structure
and processes.
We understand that it
requires a lot of work.
And there are many
areas for conservation--
lots of late night food
and coffee, of course,
and staying in the office
'til midnight or late night
troubleshooting issues and
mistakes that we have made
in the past--
and also improving
and supporting what
was previously implemented.
The third picture on the left
is our lead engineer Jose
in the office probably
around like 4:00 AM
troubleshooting the issue
with an engineer in Sydney.
It appears that this is a very
common sight in the migration
projects.
I think that we
ended up probably
staying until 6:00 AM
to solve the issue.
So big shoutout for
Jose for support.
To cover all these
topics outlined here,
we probably need another
whole day to cover that.
Instead, today we will
hyperfocus our topics
on technology during the
plan and deploy phase.
This way, we'll be able to share
more specific examples for you
which you can apply for your
own organizations immediately.
So let's talk about
some of those high level
approaches first before we get
into a little bit more details.
We talked about
those four stages
of the customer migration
journey in the previous slide.
These stages get repeated in
each phase of our migration
approach.
For the migration approach,
this is an example
of how we view the world of
complete cloud migration,
beginning from building the
foundational layer to migrating
the key workload to the cloud
as a hybrid architecture,
and building the full data
center capability in GCP,
and finally moving
data and retiring some
of those on-prem data centers.
Let's double lick
each one of those.
Phase zero-- this is where we
build our core GCP foundational
components and validate
key assumptions.
The goal of this phase
is to build up components
so that you can be ready
for future migration.
Phase one is where we
migrate a selected workload
and build automations
around GCP deployment.
This can be considered
as a hybrid architecture.
The goal of this phase to ensure
that on-prem architecture works
with the cloud and
begin to leverage
clouds for the
selected workload.
And phase two-- this is where
we build full data center
capabilities in GCP by
replicating existing
infrastructure architecture.
The goal of this phase is
to build a complete set
of the data center
capability in cloud
so any backend support for
on-prem is no longer needed.
And then obviously,
lastly, phase three
is where we migrate on-prem
customers and data to GCP
and retire the data center.
One thing that we noticed
is not all customers
will go through the complete
cloud migration journey.
Rather, we commonly adopt
the hybrid architecture.
Due to this reason, we
selected our lessons
learned from our customers
who are currently
in phase one and two for today.
While we were executing
our migration approach,
we identified and selected
five common topics
that we learned from our
customers for today's session.
First, lift and shift
or lift and what?
We'll discuss around the
beauty of the lift and shift
and then the thrill
of transform.
There are many shiny objects
and topics in the cloud.
And we wanted to
share a few examples
around how we address them.
Second, data center
meets the cloud--
one of the key benefits
of adopting cloud
is managed services to
reduce the operation
of infrastructure.
For example, all the specific
versions of the open source
may get supported as part
of the managed services.
And we'll discuss that.
Discoveries and
dependency-- our lessons
learned from our
discovery process around,
what are the downstream
dependencies?
How are we going
to approach that?
Deployment strategy--
we'll discuss around
the short-term and long-term
strategy around automation
and how we are deploying
infrastructure.
To automate or not to
automate is the key question
around that.
Finally, the testing
approach, testing approach
between hybrid and full stack--
the decision on testing
approach due to service
interdependency--
test in hybrid mode
or doing individual unit
testing and putting it together
for full integration testing?
That being said,
I'll pass to Swati
for additional details for
each topic for our lessons.
SWATI LYENGAR:
Thank you, Dillon.
All right.
Hi everyone, nice to meet you.
My name is Swati Lyengar.
I'm a strategic cloud
engineer at Google.
So I'm going to talk about
aspiration versus reality.
So to start out
with, lift and shift
can mean many different things
to many different people
and organizations.
For example, lift and shift
can be taking everything
that you have in your
on-premise and plopping it
right into the cloud.
Lift and shift can mean taking
what you have in on-premises
and taking advantage of
some services in the cloud,
such as the managed services
that Dillon had mentioned,
or some of our big
data solutions.
Or lift and shift
can mean taking
what you have in on-premises,
completely changing it,
and replatforming it to take
advantage of a completely
new technology stack.
That being said, it could
be Kubernetes Engine,
it could be App Engine, it could
be Managed Instance Groups.
It just depends on how you want
to move your technology stack.
So there's a lot of
different options here.
It can have many
different meanings.
That being said,
how do you decide
which approach to
take when you're
going through a lift and shift?
You may look at your
existing on-premise stack
and see how many different
moving parts there are.
Maybe you have 80 or
hundreds of microservices.
And so there's a lot of
different moving parts in how
you're implemented today.
And then you take a look
at your application stack.
How complex is it?
How many different
technologies is it using today
in on-premises?
And how will that
translate to the cloud?
Are your applications ready?
And then you gauge how
much uncertainty there is.
Are you moving one
to two applications
where you have a really
good understanding of what
the entire stack
looks like and how
that will look in the cloud?
Or are you dealing with
hundreds of services,
you may have some legacy stuff
sitting in the application
stack, you're not
quite sure what
that's going to look like
at the end of the day?
The other input to
consider is timeline.
Do you have a few months
to do this lift and shift?
Or do you have a few years?
And that can mean
many different things.
And lastly, what's
your risk appetite?
When you're making
this lift and shift,
how much risk do you want to
take on initially considering
all these different
factors and taking
a look at your
technology aspirations
and where you want to take
your technology stack?
But then also what are
the business use cases?
And how does that map to the
approach that you want to take?
It could be a pure lift
issue to begin with, and then
a transformation later on.
Or it could be taking on the
whole transition all at once.
All right, so let's take a look
at this example application
stack that are customer had.
And this is just
part of that stack.
So they had 60 to
80 microservices
in a global mesh,
60 to 80 per region.
You're looking at a
full stack, including
Apache Tomcat for the
frontend, Redis for caching,
DataFlow, ZooKeeper in
MySQL for data storage,
Hadoop, and much, much more.
It was the entire kitchen sink.
There was a lot in there.
And given that there were
several microservices
and a very complex
application stack,
and a lot of different
moving pieces,
they decided on the
approach to take a pure lift
and shift as much as possible.
Of course, there's always
differences, right?
Because operating in
your on-premise data
center is not exactly the same
as operating in the cloud.
You're moving to
software defined
networking versus having
hardware networking.
You're looking at
other differences,
such as the way your
access controls work
and how the managed
services work.
So there will be some
differences still.
The pure lift and shift was
what this customer journey
started with.
So the data center
meeting the cloud--
what does this mean?
What does this look like when
you start this transformation,
this journey?
So to start with, there
is a few different things
to think about.
For example, when you're
moving to a managed service,
it's beautiful, right?
With the click of a
button, you get backups.
You can, in the
case of Cloud SQL,
easily configure read replicas.
You can go ahead and
operate in multiple zones,
have your data be held in
multiple zones for higher
availability.
And you have a SLAs.
And someone's managing
the service for you.
It's beautiful.
It comes with all the
bells and whistles.
But at the same time,
you need to evaluate
how you're using that software
in your on-premises today
and how is that going to fit
into this manage service.
There may be a few differences.
For one, there could be
differences in terms of maybe
how much data you're holding
in one instance in on-premises
and differences in the
maximum amount of data
that can be held in an instance
in the managed service.
There could be
differences in terms
of how you're accessing
the service, in terms
of how you can access
it as a managed service.
So a lot of things
to think about when
deciding your approach.
What else does it mean?
So in your on-premise
environment,
it may have evolved
over time, where
you had a number of things.
Maybe for logging
and monitoring,
you have your own
in-house solutions.
You may be running
various other solutions
like Check_MK, Nagios,
Splunk, Datadog, you name it.
And then when you
move to the cloud,
you may want to look at
everything that you're running
and how you're configured to
troubleshoot in production
today in on-premise
and think, "OK,
if I'm going to centralize
my logging and my monitoring
for ease of
troubleshooting, what
is that going to look like?
How am I going to make sure
that the format is the same
and that all the logs that
were available in my on-premise
are going to be there in the
centralized logging solution?"
So there is a large
level effort that
goes into that to
make sure that, aside
from moving your services over,
you're operationally ready.
The other piece
of it is, to reap
the benefits of some of the
key features in the cloud--
for example, auto scaling
of your resources and auto
healing--
you may be moving
to a platform that
has dynamic IP addresses,
where, if an instance becomes
unhealthy, for example, in
a managed instance group,
let's say, the
managed instance group
will go ahead and delete the
instance, and then recreate it.
But it's going to come back
as a new virtual machine
with a different IP address
out of a specified subnet,
of course.
And the question is, from
an operations perspective,
are you are you ready for that?
Are your troubleshooting
playbooks
updated to be
comfortable with that?
Or do you still have the need
to SSH into a virtual machine
to do your troubleshooting
and make sure
that the logs that you
expect are there, that things
are working as expected?
So there's a lot that has
to change with respect
to the operations as well.
And then there is the concept
of pets versus cattle.
How many of you have
heard this term before,
pets versus cattle?
So you have your pets,
your pets at home.
You take care of them.
You love them.
If something's wrong
with them, you go ahead
and help them feel better.
And you might put a
little Band-Aid on
or maybe give them
additional resources.
And then there's the cattle.
So when you think about
cattle, each and every cattle
is identical.
And if you have
greater workloads,
you're just going to scale
up the number of cattle
that you have.
So that's a
philosophy difference.
And of course, you can have
either one in the cloud.
You can bring pets, or unique
instances, over into the cloud
where, let's say,
each individual VM has
its own configuration and
you need to keep it alive
and run with only
that VM and not have
it be automatically deleted.
You could do that
with a technology,
such as individual VMs or
unmanaged instance groups.
But you may want
to take advantage
of some of the auto-healing
and auto-scaling
that we had talked about
earlier and then take
the cattle approach to take
advantage of some platforms
like, for example,
managed instance groups
or where it could be scaling
up your pause in Kubernetes
engine.
So there's a little
bit of a question of,
what do your applications
look like today?
How are you
operationally addressing
the need for additional
VMs or resources?
And how can you support
that in GCP or in the cloud?
So in addition to
that, there's a mapping
of people and
processes, of course.
Is everyone comfortable
with supporting everything
in production in the cloud?
And looking at your solutions
for things like secrets,
how are you doing your
secrets management today?
And how is that going to change
when you move to the cloud?
How are you managing
your SSL certificates?
And how is that going to change?
And the list continues.
So here's an example
customer on-premise footprint
that we worked with.
And they have a number
of different data centers
in multiple regions
that were globally
distributed and connected by
point-to-point links or VPN.
And when they
moved to the cloud,
the idea was to bring up
adjacent data centers in GCP.
So what does that look like from
an architectural perspective?
So here for example, you
have a shared VPC network
on GCP, which allows you
to have a global network.
And so if the resources
within your cloud, or the VMs,
need to communicate, they can
communicate for the services
on the private IP space.
And then they wanted
[INAUDIBLE] for the interim
some tools or applications that
are still located on-premise
or perhaps some of the data
is still on premise until you
complete the migration.
Then in that case, we set
up dedicated interconnects
between the adjacent regions at
about 10 gigabits per second.
So that's what the overall
foundation looked like.
I forgot to mention that,
with the shared VPC,
the benefit there is
all your resources
can sit on the same network.
But each of the services
and the resources
can sit in their own projects.
And the access controls can be
controlled at the project level
while they still leverage
the same network, which
is beautiful.
OK, so we kind of talked about
the horizontal architecture.
Now, lets talk about
our discovery period
for looking at these
applications and services
vertically.
So here we wanted to
take a holistic approach.
And we learned early
on that, in order
to take a holistic
approach, we actually
wanted to lay the foundation,
as we did, and then
also do a deep dive in every
single application, or at least
the significant ones.
So we did this for about
45 or so applications
vertically asking
questions such as,
what's the function of this
service at a basic level?
Who are the consumers?
Where are they located?
So that way, we can
make sure that we
are able to facilitate
the connectivity.
For example, are the services
communicating internally?
Are they external consumers?
Are they on-premises
with the customer?
Are they within the same region?
Are they globally located?
So there's a lot
of variations here.
And then that also
helped us understand,
when we would test eventually,
what that would look like.
And then the other
question was, what
are the downstream
dependencies from here?
Who needs to talk
to what downstream?
And that way, from a
networking perspective,
we could make sure that it was
set up to enable that as well.
And then looking at the data
layer, what do the backends
look like today?
And on-premises,
are they shared?
Should they be shared when
they moved to the cloud?
Or are they actually using
completely different tables
and it would be OK to split them
up and put the individual data
instances with the
individual services?
So a lot of questions there.
And other questions
such as, does the data
need to be directly accessible?
Will it be accessed
from on-prem?
And additionally speaking, are
there any specific security
requirements?
Because you may
not discover them
when looking at the
entire architecture.
But when doing a deep
dive on the service,
you come across some
of these use cases,
like perhaps you have services
communicating internally
and they're using HTTPS.
And the other question
is, at the deepest level,
how are your health checks on
your services working today?
How do you identify when
a service is unhealthy?
Are you just looking at
the HTTPS response code?
Are you looking for
that plus a string?
How does that work in GCP?
Do our health checks in GCP
work exactly the same way?
So these are just an example
or a subset of the questions
that we looked at for
each of the services
to make sure that we recognized
what was unknown early on
and identified it so
that we could look at it.
So other results
of the discovery--
what came out of it?
So after going through
this deep dive discovery,
we actually fed the results back
into the overall architecture
and adjusted our architecture
accordingly, developed criteria
for determining on a per
service basis which load bounds
we should use, for example--
because there are a
few different flavors
within the platform--
determining how we're
going to do DNS resolution
during the split brain
period, figuring out
other things such as how are
we going to do our secrets
management, how are
we going to split up
or data instances for
each of the services.
Are we going to put one
service in per project?
Is this currently shared data
going to be split up into two?
So we went from there.
And one of the most
important things
that we came up with was
a blueprint, a blueprint
for, if you are going to
lift and shift application Y,
per this customer's
requirements,
and their architecture, and
the individual applications'
requirements, what
does that look like?
What's the criteria?
And what are all the
decisions that we
need to make when we're
doing that lift and shift?
So we came up with a
comprehensive blueprint
that we could follow
to really scale
when we're working
with 10's and 50
to 70 or so microservices,
which was really key.
So that way, when they're
lifted and shifted,
they're lifted and
shifted consistently.
Other things that
we looked at was
we took their
on-premise load balancer
and did a deep dive and
analysis on the features
and capabilities there
that were being used today
to see how those would map over
to capabilities in the cloud.
And then we also looked
at how individual
teams would access
the applications
and how we provisioned that.
And the biggest piece
that came out of this
was the known unknown.
So you have the
unknown unknown, which
is kind of like this
nebulous thing, which is just
like this horrible feeling.
But at least at
the end of this, we
had surfaced a number
of known unknowns
that then we could
take and tackle
and solution for so that way we
didn't have surprises later on.
So that was a key result
that really came out of this.
And now, let's move to
deployment strategy,
now that we talked about
lifting is shifting
the individual applications.
So there's a couple of
options here, right?
When you're going to
deploy into the cloud,
you can either take
everything that you have,
spin up some VMs,
spin up a platform,
move your data over, move your
image over, get things going,
and you're on your way, right?
You can start testing and
then get to Production
The other option there
is to automate it,
with a lot of
additional benefits.
Such as, if you automate--
in this scenario, there
was multiple data centers
and we wanted to deploy
consistently across each
of the data centers.
So by automating it and
taking an automated approach
with terraform, we
could consistently
do that across four
different data centers.
So what might be some
initial investment
in spending the time to code
resulted in longer term speed
and in consistency
and simplicity.
And then also, if there was
ever an emergency scenario
and you needed it
to do a redeploy,
you could go ahead and do
the redeploy because you
have the code there.
You're not worried about
sitting there and spinning up
everything individually.
So this approach nicely lent
itself to multi-data center
deployments.
And that's the
approach that we took.
OK, so now the
testing approach--
the big question in testing
in this scenario was--
there was everything
on-premises.
There was a global mesh
of services, each of which
were being deployed in every
single region for the most
part.
The question is, do we
test in a hybrid mode,
meaning that we
bring up one service
and then do integration
testing with the other services
in on-premise to verify that
it's working as expected?
Or do we go ahead and come
up with the full stack in GCP
and then do our testing?
So by taking one service and
bringing it up and testing
with on-prem, that required
a few different things.
And one is reconfiguring the
INT environment on-premise.
So we're polluting
that environment.
And the second downfall
there is that you're actually
not testing what's going
to go in production.
You're testing a
different configuration
than will actually be deployed
at the end of the day.
So you may miss things in
terms of what's not really
working together from an
integration perspective.
So for those reasons,
we took the approach
of actually testing, doing
development in parallel,
bringing up each of the
services, doing unit testing,
and then going ahead and
testing in full stack.
Because at the end
of the day, that
is what will be
deployed in production.
And you have a clear
entrance and exit criteria in
can know, "Yeah, we
should be good to go.
This will be working when
we get to production."
Now, I wanted to talk
about the path forward.
So after going through all of
that, what came out of this?
Some new guiding principles--
the first being lift and shift--
it's really critical to
have a discussion early on
and define and make sure
everyone is on the same page
as far as what a shift
in shift means to them.
Is it the lift and shift in the
purest form, a lift and shift
with some transformation, a
complete replatform, a lift
and shift and then a transform?
What does it mean?
And then as you're going
through your migration process,
when you come to a
decision, look back and say,
"Are we staying true to that?"
Or maybe you need to pivot
on that initial decision,
and really writing that
down and taking a look at it
every now and then.
The other is managed
service preferred, right?
You get all the beautiful
bells and whistles
when you're using
a managed service.
So really, that's
a nice way to go,
as long as your application
will fit in it, right?
In order for you to
use a managed service--
if you want to
drive the shiny car,
your application
needs to fit in it.
So it's just verifying that
you meet that criteria.
And the other is to take
a holistic approach.
So think about the architecture
at a horizontal level,
but then also do the diligence
to do the vertical deep dive.
So that way, you can foresee
what the known unknowns are
and discover anything
legacy that's
sitting there that you
may need to do a deeper
investigation on.
And the fourth, as far
as deployment strategy,
is especially when
you're dealing
with a complex environment
with multiple data centers
and if you want a way to
easily redeploy in an emergency
scenario, spend the
time and automate
to move faster over time,
so automate to move fast.
And as far as a
testing approach,
it's a full stack
wherever possible
or whatever is going to look
closest to your production
environment.
And in this case, that
was full stack testing
as opposed to hybrid testing.
Great, I'm going to call my
colleague Dillon back up here.
And this is a large part of
the team that was working
on this migration project.
It was an entire team.
And honestly, there's
many more people, too.
We couldn't fit
everyone on the slide.
I mean, it's really
a big team effort.
There's a lot of moving
parts and a lot of expertise
needed to lift and shift.
[MUSIC PLAYING]